welcome to the presentation on level one
exponent rules let's get started with
some problems
so if i were to ask you what
two that's a little fatter than i wanted
it to be well let's just keep it fat so
it doesn't look strange 2 to the third
times and dot is another way of saying
times
if i were to ask you what 2 to the third
times 2
to the fifth is
how would you figure that out actually
let me use a skinnier pen because that
does look bad
so 2 to the third
times 2 to the fifth well there's
there's one way that i think you do know
how to do it you could figure out that 2
to the third is 8
and that 2 to the 5th is 32
and then you could multiply them and
what 8 times 32 is let's see it's 240
plus it's 256 right you could do it that
way and that's reasonable because it's
not that hard to figure out what 2 to
the third is and what 2 to the 5th is
but if those were much larger numbers
this method might become a little
difficult so i'm going to show you using
exponent rules you can actually
multiply
exponentials or exponent numbers without
actually having to uh do as much
arithmetic or actually you could handle
numbers much larger than your normal
math skills might allow you to
so let's just think about what two to
the third times two to the fifth means
two to the third is
two times
two
times two
right
and we're multiplying that times two to
the fifth
and that's two times two times two times
two times two
so what do we have here we have two
times two times two times two times two
times two times two times two
really all we're doing is we're
multiplying two how many times well
one two three four five six seven eight
so that's the same thing as two to the
eighth
interesting
three
plus five is equal to eight and that
makes sense because two to the three is
two multiplying by itself three times to
the fifth is two multiplying by itself
five times and then we're multiplying
the two so we're gonna multiply two
eight times i hope i achieved my goal of
confusing you just now let's do another
one
if i said
squared
times
7 to the 4th that's a 4.
well that equals 7 times 7
right that's 7 squared
times and now let's do 7 to the fourth 7
times 7 times
7 times 7. well now we're multiplying
seven
by itself six times so that equals seven
to the sixth
so in general whenever i'm multiplying
exponents of the same base that's key
i can just add the exponents
so
to the 100th power
times 7
to the 50th power
and notice this is an example now
it'd be very hard without a computer to
figure out what 7 to the 100th power is
and likewise very hard without a
computer to figure out what 7 to the
50th power is but we could say that this
is equal to
to the 100
plus 50.
which is equal to
7 to the 150.
now i just want to give you a little bit
of warning make sure that you're
multiplying because if i had 7 to the
plus
7 to the 50.
there's actually very little i could do
here i couldn't simplify this number
but i'll throw out one to you just just
if i had 2
to the 8th
times 2 to the let's say 20th
well we know we can add these exponents
so that gives you
to the 28th right
what if i had
to the 8th
plus
2 to the 8th this is a bit of a trick
question
well i just said if we're adding we
can't really
do anything we can't really simplify it
but there's a little trick here is that
we actually have 2 2 to the 8th right
the 2 to the 8 times 1 to the 8 times 2.
so this is the same thing as 2
times
2 to the 8th isn't it
2 times 2 to the 8th that's just to the
8th plus itself
and 2 times 2 to the 8th well that's the
same thing as
2 to the first times 2 to the 8th
and 2 to the first times 2 to the 8th by
the same rule we just did is equal to
2 to the 9th
so i thought i would just throw that out
to you and it works even with negative
exponents if i were to say
to the negative 100
times
three
to the
say 100 oh sorry
times five this has to be a five two i
don't know what my brain was doing
five to the negative hundred times five
to the 102
that would equal
squared right i just take minus 100 plus
102. this is a 5. i saw i'm sorry for
for that that brain malfunction and of
course that equals 25.
so that's the first exponent rule now
i'm going to show you another one and it
kind of leads from the same thing
if i were to ask you what
two
to the ninth
over
2 to the 10th equals wow that that looks
like that could be a little confusing
but it actually turns out to be
the same rule because what's another way
of of writing this
well we know that this is also the same
thing as two to the ninth
times one over
two to the tenth right
and we know one over two to the tenth
well you could rewrite this as two to
the ninth
times two to the negative 10
right all i did is i took 1 over 2 to
the 10
and i flipped it and i made the exponent
negative
and i think you know that already from
level 2 exponents
and now once again we can just add the
exponents 9 plus negative 10
equals 2 to the negative 1. or we could
say that equals one-half right
so it's an interesting thing here
whatever is the bottom exponent you
could put it in the numerator like we
did here but turn it into a negative so
that leads us to the second exponent
rule a simplification is we could just
say that this equals 2
to the 9
minus 10
which equals 2 to the negative 1. let's
do another problem like that
if i said
to the 200th
over 10
to the
50th well that just equals 10
to the 200 minus 50 which is 150.
likewise if i had
to the 40th power
over seven
to the negative fifth power
this will equal seven
to the fortieth
minus
negative five
so it equals
7 to the 45th
and i want you to think about that does
that make sense well we could have
rewritten
this equation as
7 to the 40th
times
seven
to the fifth right we could have taken
this one over seven to the negative five
and turn it into seven to the fifth
and that would also just be seven to the
45.
so the second exponent rule i just
taught you actually is no different than
that first one
if the exponent is in the denominator
and of course it has to be the same base
and you're dividing you can you subtract
it from the exponent in the numerator
if they're both in the numerator
as in this case 7 to the 40th
times seven to the fifth actually
there's no numerator but if if if
they're essentially multiplying by each
other and of course you have to have the
same base
then
you add the exponents
i'm going to add one variation of this
and actually this is the same thing but
it's a little bit of a trick question
what is
two to the ninth
times
four
four to the 100th
actually maybe i shouldn't teach you
this one to you i have to wait until i
teach you the next rule but i'll give
you a little hint
this is the same thing as 2 to the ninth
times
squared to the 100th
and the rule i'm going to teach you now
is that when you have something to an
exponent and then that number raised to
an exponent you actually multiply these
two exponents so this would be 2 to the
ninth
times two
to the two hundredth
and by that first rule we learned this
would be two to the 209
now in the next module i'm going to
cover this in more detail i think i
might have just confused you
but watch the next video and then after
the next video i think you're going to
be ready to do level one exponent rules
have fun